g'day folks welcome to my channel in
this video I want to talk about the
Sabbath day and I want to give you 100
proof that Christians are not required
to keep the Sabbath day Christians are
not required to observe the sabbath day
now my main text is going to be
Colossians chapter 2 verses 16 to 17.
now I'm going to read this to you but
let me just quickly say that if you're a
Seventh-Day Adventist or a Seventh-Day
Baptist you're going to have all sorts
of objections in your mind to this
passage and you're going to try to say
well this is talking about the festival
sabbaths and not the weekly Sabbath I'm
going to refute all of that and I'm
going to show you beyond a shadow of a
doubt that this text says that the
Christian is not required to observe the
weekly Sabbath if you want a copy of my
notes click on on the link in the
description below there you have a
Google form pop-up put your name in your
email and then on the confirmation
screen there'll be a link to all of my
notes including my notes Here on on this
video on Colossians chapter 2 verse 16
to 17 and we go through all of the
objections we're going to go through
them now there's also notes to whether
or not Adam kept the Sabbath I've done a
video on that in the past but Adam did
not keep the Sabbath day in fact every
day for Adam was a day of rest and I
show that in that video as well as in my
notes but for now let's get into this
subject let me Begin by reading
Colossians chapter 2 verses 16 to 17. it
says this therefore no one is to judge
you in food and drink or in respect to a
festival or a new moon or a Sabbath day
things which are only a shadow of what
is to come but the substance belongs to
Christ now for most people this verse is
enough this this verse quite clearly
says that nobody can judge you in
regards to food and drink or in respect
to a festival or a new moon or a Sabbath
day it says very clearly here that these
things are only a shadow of what is to
come but the substance is Christ and so
for most people this this verse is a
very clear passage of scripture that
says that Christians are not required to
keep the Sabbath but for the Seventh-day
Adventist and the Sabbath day Baptist
and other Sabbath day Keepers this verse
is not enough to convince them that
Christians are not required to keep this
Sabbath they argue that the reference to
Sabbath day here is not referring to the
weekly Sabbath day but instead they
argue that this is referring to a
special Festival Sabbath day and not the
weekly Sabbath day and they give a
number of arguments to try to prove this
point the first argument they make
is that the word is translated in the
plural in the King James Sabbath days
that's the first argument that they make
it's worth noting that the word uh used
here that is translated as Sabbath day
in this translation which is the Legacy
Standard Bible the update to The New
American Standard Version the word in
the Greek appears 68 times in the New
Testament 58 times it's translated as
Sabbath day nine times it's translated
as the first day of the week the the
word week being Sabbath so the first day
of Shabbat so in other words the first
day of the week it's translated that way
nine times and it's only translated in
the plural once in Acts chapter 17 verse
2 where Paul says that where it says in
the book of Acts that Paul reasoned in
the synagogue for three Sabbath days now
that makes sense to translate it in the
plural there because it's talking about
three Sabbath days but I think think
that the way this translation has
translated it seems to be consistent
with the way it's translated all through
the New Testament it's referring to the
Sabbath day the Sabbath day now the
second argument that they make is that
every time these words Festival new moon
or Sabbath day every time these words
appear together in the Old Testament
it's always referring to a special
Festival Sabbath day now I want to show
you that that is completely false and
anybody that's that tells you that has
not looked at the passages in question
at least they haven't looked at them
carefully I'm going to show you without
a shadow of a doubt that every time
these three words appear together they
are referring to the weekly Sabbath when
it uses that word Sabbath day it's
referring to the weekly Sabbath Day
first of all it's worth noting that
Leviticus 23 now Leviticus 23 is the
chapter in Leviticus that lists all of
the festivals in one chapter and right
at the beginning it lists the weekly
Sabbath let's go there together
Leviticus chapter 23
and you see right at the beginning let
me read to you verses one and two just
to get the context of the chapter the
beginning of the chapter it says this
and Yahweh spoke again to Moses saying
speak to the sons of Israel and say to
them the appointed times and the King
James says feasts the appointed feasts
of Yahweh which you shall Proclaim as
holy convocations my appointed times are
these and the very first one here listed
is the Sabbath day it says for six days
work may be done but on the seventh day
there is a Sabbath of complete rest a
holy convocation you shall not do any
work it is a Sabbath to Yahweh in all of
your places of habitation and then as
you keep reading it lists all of the
other feasts that Israel was commanded
to observe so Verses 4 to 8 lists the
Passover verses 9 to 14 is the Feast of
harvest verses 15 to 22 is the Feast of
Weeks verses 23 to 32 is the Feast of
trumpets and verses 33 to 44 is the
Feast of booths so very clearly here the
Sabbath day the weekly Sabbath is
included in the lists of Feasts that
Israel is to observe this is very very
clear here and as I said anybody who has
made that argument that the Sabbath day
is referring to in Colossians is
referring to some special feasts Sabbath
day is completely wrong because the
wiggly Sabbath Sabbath is included in
the feasts of Israel themselves so that
argument must be dismissed on that basis
alone
the second thing is this
I think it's four times from memory I've
got four listed there may be more but
I'm pretty sure it's four that these uh
three um things the festivals humans and
sabbaths are listed together uh every
time they appear it's very clearly
referring to the weekly Sabbath three of
them the first one is the establishment
or two of them actually are the
establishment of Solomon's Temple we'll
look at that in a moment the second one
is the temple that was established in
Ezra it's described in Nehemiah that's
the passage we're going to look at where
these three are listed together and then
of course it's uh listed in the building
of ezekiel's Temple a future Temple
which is to come and then so of course
it's listed in Hosea which we'll look at
as well but it's interesting to note
that that the majority of these times
that these words are listed together
it's at the building of one of the
temples okay and when it's listed it's
describing the entire sacrificial
Ministry of the Levites let me read it
to you if we go to First Chronicles to
look at the first one first first
Chronicles chapter 23
First Chronicles going too far here
first Chronicles chapter 23 First
Chronicles chapter 23 beginning at verse
30 and this is referring to the service
of the Levites at the temple that
Solomon is about to build it says this
and they are to stand every morning to
thank and to praise Yahweh and likewise
at evening and to offer all burnt
offerings to Yahweh on the sabbaths the
new moons and the appointed times in the
numbers set by the judgments concerning
them continually before the Lord this is
describing the entire sacrificial
Ministry of the Levites the priests and
the Levites in the temple that Solomon
is about to build have a look at Second
Chronicles chapter 2 II Chronicles
chapter 2
beginning at verse 4 it says this behold
I referring to Solomon behold I am about
to build a house for the name of Yahweh
my God setting it apart to him as holy
to burn fragrant incense before him to
set out the showbread continually and to
offer burnt offerings morning and
evening on sabbaths and on new moons and
on the appointed feasts of Yahweh Our
God this being required forever in
Israel notice here that this is a
description of the entire sacrificial
Ministry a summary of the entire
sacrificial Ministry of the priests and
Levites every morning every Sabbath
every new moon and every single Feast
they are to offer sacrifices when all
three of these are listed together it's
clearly here especially in context seen
to be a reference to the weekly Sabbath
and this will be abundantly clear when
we look at ezekiel's Temple but let's
look at a Nehemiah chapter 10 to see the
next Temple
the second temple Nehemiah chapter 10
beginning at verse 32 and this of course
is when the people of God are promising
to keep yahweh's laws promising to obey
God's laws and and this of course
includes the work of the priests and the
Levites in the sacrifices that were to
be given at the temple it says this and
it's very much the same it's what we
read in uh Chronicles second chronicles
in regards to the first temple it says
this we also set ourselves under the
Commandments to give yearly one-third of
a shekel for the service of the House of
our God for the show bread for the
continual grain offering for the
continual burnt offering the sabbaths
the new moon and the appointed times
appointed feasts for the holy things and
for the sin offerings to make atonement
for Israel and all the work of the House
of our God very clearly here this is a
summary of the sacrificial work of the
priests and Levites it lists the Sabbath
days the new moons and pointed times the
appointed face clearly in context of the
overall context of what's going on the
weekly Sabbath is included here let's
have a look at ezekiel's Temple the
third one Ezekiel 45
verse 17.
and this is really describing the role
of the prince to come the role of the
prince to come in providing burnt
offerings for all of the sacrifices that
will take place at the new Temple the
temple known as ezekiel's Temple which
says this in verse 17 Ezekiel 45 verse
17. it shall be the prince's part to
provide the burnt offerings the grain
offerings and the drink offerings at the
feasts on the new moons and on the
sabbaths and all the appointed times of
the House of Israel he shall provide the
sin offering the grain offering the
burnt offering and the peace offerings
to make atonement for the house of
Israel now just a few verses later it
starts to go into the application of
this chapter 46 and remember there are
no chapter and verse divisions in the
original text this is just a few verses
later chapter 46 verse 1 it says this
thus says Lord Yahweh the Gate of the
inner court facing the East shall be
shut the six working days but it shall
be opened on the Sabbath day and opened
for the day of the new moons then the
prince shall enter by way of the porch
of the gate from the outside and stand
by the post of the gate then the priests
shall provide his burnt offering
referring to the offering supplied by
the prince as it says in verse 17 a few
verses earlier then the priest shall
provide his burnt offering and his peace
offerings and he shall worship at the
threshold of the gate and then go out
but the gate shall not be shut until
evening very clearly here this is
referring to the weekly Sabbath
so earlier in verse 17 when it says the
Priestess Supply is to supply all of the
sacrifices for the new moons the
sabbaths and appointed times the
appointed face it clearly included the
weekly Sabbath because the context when
we get to verse 46 that shows the
application of that clearly specifies
the weekly Sabbath so to me this
argument that when you see these three
listed together it's referring only to
some special Festival Sabbath that
argument is very weak in light of the
context Hosea chapter 2 verse 11 is the
other one that they use Hosea chapter 2
verse 11.
and the context here in Hosea chapter 2
verse 11
is really the Judgment of God the
Judgment of God and God going to bring
an end of course for a time because
Israel returned to the land uh to the
new moons the feasts the Newmans and the
sabbaths it says this Hosea chapter 2
verse 11 it says I will also cease all
her Joy her feasts her new moons her
sabbaths and all her appointed times all
her appointed fists this is speaking
about a time of God's judgment where he
was going to bring an end to all of this
stuff for a period of time of course he
stuff and it's not referring to just
some special Sabbath day it's referring
to the weekly Sabbath as well all of the
sabbaths all the feasts all the Newmans
and all the sabbaths were going to come
to an end because of God's judgment upon
the people of Israel
now with that in mind let's go back to
Colossians
and read this text in light of all of
that so that we can see very clearly
what this passage is all about
Colossians chapter 2 verses 16 to 17 it
says therefore no one is to judge you in
fact if we just go a few verses earlier
we can really see the context of it
it says in verse 13 and you being dead
in your transgressions and the
uncircumcision of your flesh he made you
alive with him having graciously
forgiven us all of our transgressions
having canceled out the certificate of
debt consisting of decrees against us
which was hostile to us he has also
taken it out of the way having nailed it
to the Cross having disarmed the rulers
and authorities he made a public display
of them having triumphed over them in
him therefore no one is to judge you in
food and drink on respect to a festival
or a new moon or a Sabbath day these
things are only a shadow of what is to
come but the substance belongs to Christ
clearly Christians are not required to
keep the Sabbath day very clearly here
the festivals new moons and sabbaths the
fact that they're all listed together
means it includes the weekly Sabbath
because when you look at it in the Old
Testament it's always inclusive of the
weekly Sabbath these things are a shadow
of things to come the substance is
Christ the Sabbath day is a picture of
our salvation by faith by resting in
Jesus Christ and what he has done
instead of trusting in our own works and
if you read Hebrews chapter 4 you'll see
that that's what that chapter is all
about I hope you've liked this video if
you have please consider subscribing hit
the Bell notification button I'll see
you in the comments section and you'll
see me in my next video
thank you